how did the seahorse get its shape a new
study published in the journal Nature
communications explains how the seahorse
is curiously curved trunk
bent head and long snout help it to
catch food
[Music]
seahorses evolved from straight bodied
swimmers like these pipe fish to work
out why such a straight body might
become s-shaped researchers Sam van
Wattenberg yurt rose and Lara ferry
compared the way pipe fish feed with the
way seahorses capture their prey
both Pike fish and sea horses feed on
small shrimp and larval fishes which
they catch in a two-stage process called
pivot feeding this slow-motion footage
taken by the researchers shows how they
rapidly rotate the head upwards then use
suction to draw the prey into their
mouth but the suction only works over
short distances so you have to move your
mouth very close very quickly to make a
catch the researchers found that the
seahorses unique anatomy increases its
strike distance the distance between the
eyes that spy dinner and the mouth that
eats it
this animation shows how its s-shaped
body enables the seahorse to reach
further forward for its prey compared
with a straight bodied pipefish it's
subtle but small changes like this drive
evolution in the wild seahorses tend to
hide along the edges of reefs or in
seagrass beds and wait for their prey to
swim by they often attached themselves
to the sea grass for camouflage as they
sit and wait in this case an increased
strike distance is clearly an advantage
pipe fish on the other hand generally
swim towards their prey so strike
distance is less important that's why it
seems an s-shaped body evolved alongside
a sit and wait strategy in seahorses and
that's how the seahorse got its
curiously curved shape
[Music]
[Music]
you